[Musique]
bonjour à rien de ce fait à mon futur
vous avez des enfants
oui j'ai une fille de 14 ans quoi c'est
ce que je craignais vous êtes allergique
a dû finir sur ses pas des poux un nom
c'est moi des pouvoirs je vous souhaite
que l'adolescence ne soit pas à
l'éditeur mais fois hélas que tu fous
mettre en retard à l'école j'y vais pas
fait grève hier à l'école fumée sortir
vendredi soir je reste zen
alors bonne journée lille à l'attenté
qu'un sortie toi bah oui mais c'est pas
une raison
maman c'est ma vie qui en dépend et tu
sais que suis raisonnable et que tu peux
faire confiance
surprise j'ai 14 ans avant toi tu montes
tu fais de toi je serai vigilant une ado
en colère peut-être imprévisible this
way avec qui je rentre à quelle heure
[Musique]
ça
c'est fou de la gueule on parle de ta
fille on danse d'abord comme de merde de
gosses gâtés pourris son nouveau
téléphone qu'un n'est pas tactile faut
appuyer sur les touches
c'est quoi ça tout est sous contrôle
mais pas de problème je gère
[ __ ] qu'est jury d'être différente de
toi maman de faire autrement mais
regarde moi jusqu'à quel âge et reste à
dos parce que mon genre de dire ça mais
moi aussi j'ai une adolescente à la
maison et beaucoup de chance ça se passe
extrêmement bien tout va bien ici
oui parce que votre fille m'a dit t'es
pas ils apprennent chez moi je la carte